it's time we discuss ultra maga oh cool
joe biden is warning about the ultra
maga agenda that really does sound like
a trump anime or or manga you know the
ultra maga and they're like fighting
they always end up making uh the right
sound super cool
first it was deplorable
now it's uh now it's ultra maga
ultra mega
what does it mean
it's awesome
ultra what is that
look look joe biden was talking about
the roe v wade thing
he's insane he's an insane person okay i
i just have to say that and you know i
always i'm always a little reluctant to
say that because there's gonna be some
you know
red pill curious left-leaning person
who's like i guess i'll check out tim
cast irl then then they hear something
like that and they get scared and they
they run away and they're like no he's
far right let me just let me just
explain okay give me a second let me let
me try and break it down for you
maga is the most extreme political
organization in american history that's
a quote from joe biden the weather
underground was a thing they blew stuff
up and killed people okay biden warned
that after roe v wade was struck down
conservatives might try to ban lgbtq
kids from classrooms
where did that come from
it's like made it up just literally made
that up that's not a thing that's not
happening anywhere but you see this is
what happened
recently joe biden was asked about title
42 and his response was well you gotta
get the scientists have got to review it
you know and then we'll appeal to the
courts and it's like wait what bro
joe are you talking about
are you talking about covet or something
you're talking about immigration we're
talking he confused the mass uh mandate
repeal with immigration the man is not
well
he is not able to articulate his
thoughts this maga crowd is really the
most extreme political organization
that's existed in american history all
right i'd just like to make one point
joe biden in response to news that the
supreme court
voted to overturn roe v wade said that
that maga is the most extreme political
organization in american history
and it is it is based upon
overturning roe v wade all right here
you go joe biden changed position on roe
v wade in 1982 when biden was a senator
from delaware he voted to end roe v wade
under former president ronald reagan the
administration was focused on ending
abortion rights at the federal level an
amendment was proposed to the senate
judiciary committee to allow individual
states to overturn roe v wade he said
i'm probably a victim or a product you
know how everyone afraid of my
background citing his catholic
upbringing
if anything's more extreme today it's
joe biden
that's a hypocrite
no look the psychological thing
projection right we talk about this all
the time uh that's what's happening here
obviously you know you mentioned this
tim but
maga you know in a lot of ways is left
of where the republican party is 20
years ago i mean 10 years ago 10 years
ago um you know you look at like trade
and things like that that was those were
issues where the democrats were um but
but but joe biden in the democratic
party we're talking about abortion until
the moment of birth we're talking about
sex changes for kids we're talking about
censoring free speech so i think when he
says that ultra maga which is really
cool by the way uh is the most dangerous
political movement i i think the truth
is that the democrats are are really
threatening that now the reason biden is
able to get away with this and the
reason why a substantial number of
people in the country will believe him
is because of the media
the media
memory holds every single example of
left-wing extremism and amplifies
anything they can pin on republicans so
we'll always remember the trespasses at
the capitol
but we won't remember the people who
bombed the capital in the 1980s uh the
leftists linked to the weather on the
ground as as you said tim um actually
there might have been another different
left-wing extremist groups group even
i'm forgetting the details there's so
many even i'm forgetting the details
because the media just doesn't
talk about these things ceaselessly
here's here's the issue you know they
come out and they're like but there's so
many far-right extremists and i'm like
there are many far-right extremists sure
but do they have any institutional power
are the people who stormed into the
capital on january 6 working at cnn or
the new york times are any of those
people are are they being supported and
defended by cnn in the new york times oh
well when black lives matter and antifa
rioted across this country in 2020
causing billions of dollars in damage
and i think it resulted in between 26
and 32 dead they were actively defended
by the sitting vice president and
president
and the media actively defended them my
favorite is fiery but mostly peaceful
so if i take issue with that you know
and then you're like but what about the
insurrectionists and i'm like oh the
people who are violent should go to
prison but those people don't have any
support from the major cultural
institutions they don't work there you
actually have active antifa people at
the new york times
actively okay you don't you don't have
that with the mag people but they're
like but they're police officers i'm
like dude and what like bumble haven in
in in buffu
podunk yeah okay i'm really worried
about the po dunk cop who drove a couple
hundred miles and rioted arrest the guy
put him in jail fine i get it but that
is not an institution that is going to
harm my life and look at the difference
here between the two parties right the
republicans do everything they can to
disavow the insurrectionists disavow the
far-right you know the alt-right people
the democrats create gofundmes for
bailout funds for the pro the the mostly
peaceful protesters
i pulled up this uh the bombing you were
talking about in the capital 1980s a
far-left group called m19
uh bombed the senate huh it was women i
think it was a group of women but it was
like a male oh it wasn't all women it
was like looks like four women and two
guys they call it like a yeah i've never
heard of i don't think i've ever heard
of m19 until tonight so thank you yeah
i think a lot of people haven't heard
about it because
whoever controls the history books
whoever controls the news doesn't want
us remembering it uh you know we have an
alternative news media now which is
great we probably need alternative
history as well yeah their communist
communist organization well and has
everybody forgotten about asada shakur
and her shootout on the jersey turnpike
that was in i want to say the 70s i'm
not sure exactly but that's just another
thing that they never ever talk about
incredibly dangerous people literally
died it's just not a big oh this is
crazy look i pulled up m19
from 1982 to 1985 m19 ceo committed a
series of bombings including bombings of
the national war college the washington
navy yard computing center the israeli
aircraft industries
new york city's south african consulate
wow the washington navy yard officers
club
they've got a whole bunch here man yeah
but there's no way those guys are the
most extremist movement in american
history that's well well from my god no
no hold on hold on hold hold on let's be
honest and be real
they didn't vote for trump okay so
everything else it's like it's it's bad
but it's not quite there
it's really like it becomes obvious as
you learn how governments will use
organizations as like fall guys when
it's time
it's it's explosive but mostly peaceful
yes
it's bad but not ultra bad yeah exactly
bad
we even have a recent examples i mean
that's from the 80s but do you guys
remember the family research council
shooting that happened like six years
ago seven years ago no one talks about
this but this they were targeted for
being an anti-gay hate group and someone
went in there with chick-fil-a
sandwiches was planning to put
chick-fil-a sandwiches on the dead
corpses of all the people that worked
there this happened it wasn't wasn't
that like the splc yeah it was the splc
named them and then so they went after
them but no i mean you also had the the
bernie guy who went and shot up the
baseball game
i don't think mag is an organization it
means make america great again it was a
it was a phrase that donald trump used
you could say that people are rallying
around and attempting to create some
sort of organized movement based on
donald trump like a campaign but there's
mega is just a statement that means make
america great again so i don't
understand why he's trying to create a
political assessment out of that this is
what's this is what's happening and uh
i'll i'll i'll say it early just for you
john civil war okay now hold on
i'll tell i'll explain
this leak from the initial draft
never happened before that a draft was
leaked like this there was a meme post
from some leftist guy that had like 20
000 retweets or some huge number and he
was saying that his law professor told
him
this is an egregious violation of the
court and the integrity of the court and
he was like i responded taking away
women's rights is a worse scandal
and the professor said i'm not talking
about politics i'm talking about for the
courts and what they need to do
and then the person responded women are
losing their rights across this country
and you're worried about this and i'm
just like i don't look if the if the
people who are
supposed to be coming into the courts
do not care for the process of law the
process of justice then you're going to
have
psychotic activists saying
precedent law and the fabric of this
nation doesn't matter what matters is
what i think is right
so you ca
those kind of people in courts you're
going to go into court and be like i
didn't break the law the law says i'm
allowed free speech there's no laws and
i can't say naughty words and he goes i
don't care
prison that's what you end up getting
you get activist judges like who was it
was it um
wasn't was it soda mayor no no was it
kagan one of the supreme court justices
who said that uh i don't understand why
the the federal mayor yeah which like i
don't understand why the states would
have this power not the federal
government or something like that and
everyone was just like
screams in 1910 yeah right
it's like you're a supreme court justin
you don't know these things so we i can
rag but i'll tell you what's happening
to go back with why joe biden said maga
is the most extreme
if you put out an article or or a
rallying cry
that says donald trump is racist
it will not work again you've got to up
the ante so the next day it's he's the
worst racist you can't say that again
you got to up the ante the next day you
say he's almost as bad as hitler
you can't say it again so the next day
he is as bad the next day he's worse
than
you have to keep escalating it because
people want that fix of anger and hatred
and they need a reason to hate and be
angry
so joe biden comes out and he needs a
way to rile people up for
the midterms
the roe v wade thing leaks and he says
they're the most extreme organization in
american history and you know you know
what he's doing he's targeting 18 year
olds
18 year olds who don't know about the
weather underground who don't know about
m19 ceo who don't know about these
bombings who don't even know about joe
biden
because we've had these leftists on the
show and they're like i don't know
anything about biden nor's
administration or what he did with obama
and i'm like well they blipped kids but
they don't know that
he says it may 915 i don't know nothing
about no m19 m19 co it's uh the may 19th
communist organization
so here's what's gonna happen
right now i think the one thing that's
preventing
just balls to the wall chaos and
violence boomers
boomers were 30 years old or so in the
90s and they
they were the political faction that
overlapped democrat republican to this
day it is still mostly true we had a
boomer on the show recently we talked to
her and she didn't know anything about
what was going on with our generation's
politics
when the boomers age out retiring
exiting politics and or passing on
that tether is gone and you're going to
have millennials who are very much at
odds in the culture where i mean look at
where we are compared to where the young
turks are
but it's it's all screaming at each
other
but we do have young people and there
are some older people involved get me
wrong boomers are involved but they're
overtly fighting in the streets
what happens when gen z and jen alpha
are raised
in a world dominated by millennial world
view which is hyper-polarized what
happens when the next generation comes
in raised by millennials millennials are
going to have kids
gen z is going to have kids and their
kids are going to be raised in those
ideologies completely bifurcated
politics in this country that's when
chaos happens the one thing that i think
is is missing from all of the
discussions about escalation of violence
and hyperpolarization in this country is
how demographics shape what's going to
happen in this country
if in the 2000s conservatives were
having more kids than liberals then by
2020 you would have a generation that
was slightly more conservative surprise
surprise we literally have that only
slightly though the left doesn't have
kids they have your kids so as long as
they're in schools indoctrinating now
you've got millennial conservatives and
you know xenial i guess necessarily gen
x because they're a little older
but people in their 40s and down to
millennial are fighting in these schools
and complaining about it you do have
some boomers involved some older
generation stuff
they're fighting about the
indoctrination the indoctrination is
likely going to stop because of the
culture wars or at least i believe it
will
the left is going to react revolt
the one thing that may happen is if they
can't indoctrinate conservative kids
then leftism just fizzles out because
these these people i mean let's be real
they don't have kids if they get
pregnant they abort their babies and
they are actually moving towards
sterilizing or at least permanently
damaging damaging the reproductive
organs of their children
mathematically it just stands to reason
20 years from now
it's gonna be two to one conservative in
this country yeah but that's assuming
that they don't have your kids that's
the thing about horizontal gene
translation there's there's vertical
gene translation which is parent to
child then there's horizontal which is
your environment changes your genetics
and if you have enough kids getting
brainwashed with tv where they're being
told they're transgender they're being
told they're evil or wrong that's they
could very well become that daily memes
versus genes the entire education system
is leftist
um and then you also have culture and
people on social media telling you you
have to be left to be cool or else you
get cancelled if you're an
impressionable teenager you're going to
respond to those things
but uh not if you're a french teenager
apparently one of the interesting things
i've noticed from the recent uh french
election was that uh
the younger people in france tend to be
more supportive of the writer which is
an interesting contrast with america but
this
uh
i know i think that tracks exactly with
you know what we're talking about that
the in the 2000s conservatives were
having slightly more kids than liberals
20 years that means someone who was born
in in 2000 they're 22 years old they're
voting and they're more likely to be
conservative because conservatives had
more kids that's it it doesn't matter if
you win the culture war it doesn't
matter if uh you've been effective in
your persuasion
this to start the most influential
element is the parents that's why
they're going for schools they need to
they need to cut the parents out because
they know parents are more conservative
than they are
right and i think the white pill in all
this is we do seem to see a movement
pushing back against this indoctrination
i think that's what the virginia
governor's race last year was all about
and you know the the thing here that i
see is that i don't really see when we
talk about civil war uh which is always
a fun topic to me it seems like
conservatives won't ever be the
instigators but but progressives
leftists woke up woke people will
and so it's really critical i think for
us to uh you know to take back power to
be willing to use the government to to
shut down some of these institutions
that are trying to do this
indoctrination um to really go after
them and so that's that's like one of
the biggest debates on the right right
now is like are we going to continue to
be this like small government party that
lets schools do whatever they want to
your kids or are we going to take a more
active role and say no absolutely not
parents should have some control over
that yeah the meme works both directions
works in multiple directions you may
have indoctrination towards one thing
but just this show having you you
listening to this right now are you are
being indoctrinated
this is the part of the conversation and
if you want your kids to learn this kind
of information let them listen to this
kind of conversation it works and so we
can we can heal the earth and we can
heal our minds and our children's you
know forethought
proactively by by
exposing kids to good ideas and this is
why for me it all comes back to internet
censorship i think this is the most
important issue for all of these culture
war topics because if you control the
flow if you can't control the flow of
information then you can't indoctrinate
people i remember being in college and
you know uh hearing absolute nonsense
from uh from gender studies professors
and things and thinking that sounds a
bit
weird i'm gonna go and look things up on
the internet see what the internet has
to say about this particular debate
about the social construction of gender
and then i'd find threads on 4chan and
reddit that breaks it that broke it all
down and explain and explain to me that
yes i was absolutely correct you are
listening to nonsense right now here's
the facts here's the data
um so it comes back to internet
censorship if you think this is why
they're so fixated on it this is where
they're so determined to stop elon musk
uh bringing free speech back to twitter
if they can't if they can't control
those choke points of information uh the
indoctrination machine completely
collapses and as as these left-wing
institutions you know really the clown
themselves i think people are the media
for example you look cnn's ratings
msnbc's ratings always going down uh you
know some of these things i think people
realize okay these institutions are bad
but as olim said like if you take away
our ability to access information take
away our ability to
go to the daily wire or go to some of
these other institutions to kind of
counter this programming then you know
people are going to say well i i heard
that trump's a racist i guess that's
true because that's the only source that
they they saw they're losing
i hear it more and more and and you know
the craziest thing to me actually is
having people say things like you know i
started watching your videos and then i
kind of realized about all the lies
and it's just it's really fascinating
because we have been doing this now for
for a little while but it's not just
it's it's about you know steven crowder
it's about even people like jimmy dore
you know who's a leftist but who are
challenging the establishment it's about
breaking points with crystal and and
sagar these more and more people are
rising up doing shows just saying no to
the manipulation and the lies so it'll
be it'll be fascinating when these
institutions lose their power thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you